Professor David
Blight:
Good morning.
I'm going to talk today about
turning points,
and on Thursday about turning
points, and beyond that,
probably, about turning points.
But let me lay out right now my
own sort of selective list,
short list, of the most
important turning points in the
Civil War;
make the list and then we will
come back to them.
Now this is any military
historian's, or any Civil War
historian's guess,
of course.
But there's no question that
the Antietam campaign of 1862 is
a major turning point in the
Civil War, and I'll select that
as my first.
There are things happening
before that that are terribly
important, like the saving of
Richmond,
against McClelland's Peninsula
Campaign in June and July of
'62.
But it is this first invasion
of the North by Robert E.
Lee, culminating in the
bloodiest single day of the
Civil War;
over 5000 dead,
23,000 casualties in eight
hours, on fields along a little
creek in southwestern Maryland
that not only stopped this first
major invasion of the North and
this threat of a southern army
to northern soil,
northern resources,
and northern cities,
but it of course resulted in
Lincoln's Emancipation
Proclamation,
which transformed the purpose
of the war on both sides;
back to that in a second.
The second major turning point
in the war, militarily,
I'd argue, as most people do,
was the Battle of Gettysburg in
July of 1863 and the day after
the three days' battle at
Gettysburg.
The bloodiest encounter of the
entire war, if you add up the
three days' casualties of almost
56,000 dead and wounded,
in three days--that battle,
of course, stopped Lee's second
invasion of the North,
and we'll come to that in a
moment, at least in brief terms.
On the day after Pickett's
Charge at Gettysburg on the
4^(th) of July 1863,
the kind of citadel river town
or city of Vicksburg,
Mississippi fell to Union
forces,
after a siege of nearly six
months.
When Grant took Vicksburg on
the 4^(th) of July in 1863,
it virtually opened up the
entire Mississippi River to
Union control;
it cut geographically the
Confederacy in half;
it isolated Arkansas,
Louisiana and Texas from the
rest of the Confederacy.
It was without a question,
at least in the long-term,
a decisive turning point in the
war in the West.
A third major turning point,
I'd argue, is the Fall of
Atlanta in September 1864;
and we'll come that later on,
after the break.
A fourth major turning point in
the war, politically,
without any question I think,
is the Election of 1864,
the only time in modern history
that a republic attempted to
hold a general election in the
midst of civil war and succeeded
in doing it.
The re-election of Lincoln in
1864 was absolutely crucial to
the prosecution of the war to
the ends,
the Lincoln administration at
least, by then,
had determined to fight it.
But without the fall of
Atlanta, the first week of
September 1864,
it's not at all clear Lincoln
would've been re-elected,
and more on that later.
And then fifth,
you could argue,
I would argue,
the greatest single turning
point in the Civil War,
deeply related to these
military battlefront affairs,
is emancipation.
The emancipation of 4.2 million
American slaves in the midst of
eventually all-out,
near total war by the North on
the South, to destroy southern
society and its institutions,
transformed American history,
more than just transforming a
war.
That's the theme of this
lecture and Thursday's lecture,
and even to some extent beyond.
It is those results beyond the
battlefield that ultimately it
is our obligation to understand.
It's important,
it's an obligation to
understand why the Battle of
Antietam turned the way it did,
and it's an obligation to
understand why Lee is invading
the North a second time in 1863,
and why that encounter at
Gettysburg turned out the way it
did.
But by then it is a war being
fought for something very
different, and much,
much larger than it had been at
the outset.
One way into this story is a
very simple quotation in one of
those interviews held with
former slaves in the WPA Oral
History Narratives in the 1930s.
These were the interviews,
over 3000 of them done with
ex-slaves, many of them in their
eighties, some even in their
nineties.
A guy named Cornelius Garner
was interviewed in 1937,
at age 91.
He was asked if he had fought
in the Civil War,
and Cornelius replied to his
interviewer,
who was a black interviewer in
this case, "Did I fight in the
War?
Well if I hadn't you wouldn't
be sittin' there writin' at me
today."
He then went on to describe a
corner of his native Norfolk,
Virginia where slave auctions
used to be conducted on New
Year's Day.
"That day, New Year's Day,"
said Garner, should be kept by
all the colored people.
That is the day of freedom.
And they ought to remember
Frederick Douglass too.
Frederick Douglass told Abe
Lincoln, 'Give the black man
guns and let him fight.'
And Abe Lincoln say,
'If I give him a gun,
when it come to battle he might
run.'
And Frederick Douglass say,
'Try him, and you'll win the
war.'
And Abe said,
'All right, I'll try him.'"
Now that's a simplistic,
homespun explanation for how
emancipation came about.
Over 180,000 African-Americans
will end up in the Union armies.
But old Cornelius wasn't
entirely wrong.
All right, back to Virginia,
in 1862.
I'll put the outline back up if
we need it.
I don't know if you can see all
of that but I hope you can see
some of it.
I left you with McClellan's
army on the peninsula having
been defeated.
I thought I'd show you a couple
of magnificent Mathew Brady
photographs.
Photography,
of course, had finally come
into its own.
The Civil War would be the
first major event in world
history to be photographed on a
large scale,
and it's in part what made Ken
Burns's film possible,
especially the use of that
camera they now that have that
can go into an old daguerreotype
type,
which isn't any bigger than
this, and make it seem like a
giant panorama.
This is a photograph taken
behind Union troops overlooking
the Cumberland River in May
1862;
that's before the Battle of the
Seven Days, that's during the
march by McClellan's army up the
peninsula.
I don't how well you can see
that but that's an absolutely
stunning photograph of a Union
wagon train on one of these
makeshift bridges.
They would build these things
in a few hours,
over all these rivers,
which in May of 1862 were
flooding constantly.
It's Union troops crossing the
Chickahominy River,
just east of Richmond,
May 1862.
Now, what happened next of
course was--and this is where I
left you--was Lee's fateful
decision to not stay and just
defend Richmond;
so not just leave the war in
Central Virginia.
Having defeated or held back
McClellan's army,
and with a certain degree of
confidence that McClellan
probably would be McClellan and
not move,
he decided to invade the North.
Now there were all these
high-level councils of war in
Richmond between Jefferson
Davis, Lee and his generals.
There were arguments for and
against it.
But Lee won the day,
and the argument,
and he went west behind the
Blue Ridge mountains and invaded
the North through the upper part
of the Shenandoah Valley,
the goal of which was to not
attack Washington,
D.C., by any means--I think I
have a better map possibly;
yes, maybe that helps a little
better--not to attack Washington
or necessarily to even threaten
Philadelphia directly.
Lee had no intention of taking
over any northern cities.
He couldn't do that.
He didn't have the resources.
He didn't have an army big
enough.
How would he have occupied them?
But what he most wanted to do,
the aim of this invasion,
was wanting to take the war out
of ravaged Virginia;
to threaten northern cities,
especially the U.S.
capital;
to try to bring about--and
Great Britain was on the brink
of this, and I'll come back to
that foreign policy diplomatic
story a bit later--but Great
Britain was truly on the brink
of near recognition,
at least a kind of
quasi-recognition of the
Confederacy, and the theory here
was that if the Confederate
forces could win a major
victory,
somewhere on northern soil,
get into Pennsylvania,
do it twice over,
live off the land,
possibly even force the
evacuation of the U.S.
capital, that news of that in
Great Britain might bring about
British recognition of the
Confederacy as the legitimate
government,
and especially give the
Confederacy access to its navy,
if not even the possibility of
ground forces.
And by the way,
a British force had already
been sent to Canada in early
1862 for the possibility of
intervention in the American
Civil War.
Now, there was also a theory
here at work that is going to be
dead wrong.
Lee believed,
as did other Confederate
leaders, that in Maryland,
in particular,
there was a great deal of
Confederate sympathy and
sentiment, and a lot of young
Maryland men,
the theory was,
eager to join the Confederate
forces if they could just get
out of Maryland.
And that marching Confederate
Army was going to attract them;
at least that was the theory.
The problem was when young men
actually saw that Confederate
Army, they were appalled,
because that Confederate Army
that invaded across the Potomac
River--they crossed the Potomac
on September 4 and September 5,
1862--was an army that had
apparently remarkable,
almost miraculous morale;
they were winners.
They had just defeated a Union
Army with McClellan's whole
force still back on the
peninsula.
The 40 to 50,000 Union troops
still guarding Washington,
DC were decisively,
horribly defeated in the Battle
of Second Manassas,
the last two days of August,
the 29^(th) and 30^(th) of 1862.
That Union Army retreated once
again--fought on the same fields
as First Bull Run,
thirteen months
earlier--retreated into
Washington, DC.
Washington, DC,
on September 1^(st) 1862,
was like a giant field
hospital.
There were some 3 to 4,000
wounded Union soldiers all over
the streets of Washington,
a broken army,
with McClellan's army now
retreating back up the
Chesapeake and the Potomac and
this huge flotilla trying to get
to Washington in case Lee
actually attacked Washington.
But the army Lee had was
starving, they weren't very well
fed, and they weren't very well
clad.
Here's one description of a
young Marylander who saw the
Confederate Army.
He said it was nothing but,
quote, "a set of ragamuffins.
It seemed as if every cornfield
in Maryland had been robbed of
its scarecrows.
None had any underclothing.
My costume consisted of a
ragged pair of trousers,"--this
guy apparently joined--"a
stained dirty jacket,
an old slouch hat,
the brim pinned up with a
thorn, a begrimed blanket over
my shoulder,
a grease-smeared cotton
haversack full of apples and
corn, a cartridge box full and a
musket.
I was barefooted.
I had a stone bruise on each
foot.
There was no one there who
would not have been run in by
the police had he appeared on
the streets of a normal city."
And there's plenty of testimony
in the record,
though a lot of young Maryland
men came out to see this now
famous army of Robert E.
Lee, took one look or one
smell, as one put it,
and went back to their farms.
Lee will get almost no real
recruits, out of Maryland.
What they will do in Maryland,
however, is capture several
hundred slaves and return them,
or take them,
to Virginia.
They're going to do the same
thing in 1863 in the Gettysburg
campaign on an even larger
scale.
Kidnapping was also part of the
Confederate army's job.
Now, the battle would not have
occurred at Antietam except for
the famous--and it's true--lost
order.
Here's what happened.
Lee went into Maryland.
The Union Army is all around
Washington, D.C.;
there's really no army up in
Maryland to stop him,
yet.
He divided his army in three
parts, three corps,
about 20,000,
roughly, men each.
And they were spread out around
Maryland about twenty miles
apart, over a sixty-mile
stretch.
Stonewall Jackson's corps was
sent to Harpers Ferry.
The other two corps,
they were separated,
at least by twenty miles in
between them,
these three parts of his army.
One of the cardinal rules of
the old manuals they were taught
in at West Point was,
quote, in the old,
in Henri Jomini's Military
Manual of Conduct,
it said,
"never divide your forces in
the presence of the enemy."
It's exactly what Lee had done.
The problem was that the Union
command was about to find out
quickly.
Lee wrapped orders around three
cigars, sent his courier out to
the three corps commanders,
over the course of more than a
day, to deliver the orders.
But the orders were lost,
and they were found by a
private in an Indiana regiment
whose name was B.W.
Mitchell-- the 27^(th) Indiana
Volunteers to be exact--who
picked up this bundle of three
cigars,
with paper wrapped around it,
and he read the orders,
and at the bottom it said,
"R.
E.
Lee." And he apparently said
something like,
"I've heard of him."
And Lee was already a kind of
budding legend because of the
Seven Days and because of Second
Manassas.
And he gave it to his colonel
who gave it to his
brigadier-general who quickly
gave it to other generals.
Lincoln had little choice but
to put McClellan back in charge.
His commander at Second
Manassas had been a general
named John Pope,
who had been thoroughly
defeated and had had a nervous
breakdown;
seriously, he had a mental
breakdown during the Second
Manassas battle,
and Pope was out of action,
to say the least,
and he would've been put out of
action anyway.
So Lincoln puts McClellan back
in command, in Washington D.C.,
and within hours McClellan was
delivered Lee's orders,
just as though there had been a
fourth cigar for McClellan.
McClellan looked at these
orders;
but they were discovered,
by the way, on the 13^(th) of
September of 1862.
McClellan read them by that
night.
The orders were basically to
have all parts of Lee's Army
concentrate, rather slowly,
but concentrate toward the area
of Sharpsburg,
Maryland, which is right here
along Antietam Creek.
Sharpsburg is a little town,
Antietam's a little river.
But they were to congregate
there within the next,
oh, three to four days.
McClellan now has at his
command about 90,000 troops.
If he marched them quickly he
had the opportunity to defeat
Lee's Army in parts.
But McClellan was McClellan.
He sat on the lost order for
about two days before he decided
(1) whether to believe it,
(2) what to do about it.
Lee quickly discovered that his
orders never reached his
commanders and he worried,
he sent out new orders to
concentrate as fast as possible
near Sharpsburg.
McClellan finally moved slowly
from the camps around
Washington, up toward
Sharpsburg.
They encountered each other at
a place called South Mountain at
the end of the day of the
15^(th) of September 1862,
and a battle of a sort was
fought there.
It was only a rearguard sort of
thing.
Lee retreated out of the South
Mountain pass,
down into this little valley
around Sharpsburg,
Maryland, which is just above
the Potomac River.
Now Lee was taking a tremendous
risk here, because one of those
other rules they'd been taught
was never engage an enemy,
at least in full force,
with a major river behind you.
But that's exactly what
happened.
They fought the Battle of
Antietam on September 17,1862,
as I already said,
the bloodiest single day of the
Civil War.
They fought in cornfields,
they fought across open fields,
they fought along a sunken
road,
they fought along a famous
bridge now known as the Burnside
Bridge.
I have a couple of photographs
to show you.
They fought along what's known
as the Hagerstown Road,
along which 48 hours after the
battle one of Mathew Brady's
photographers took this awful
photograph.
These are Confederate dead
along that road.
There are many,
many photographs taken at
Antietam.
This is another one of Union
dead lined up for burial,
a line of dead probably 75
yards long.
Antietam was in no way
necessarily a decisive or
strategic victory for either
side.
I want you to see this
photograph because of its irony.
You've probably seen this one
before.
At the end of the day at
Antietam there were about 23,000
casualties on both sides,
over 5,000 dead.
And you may remember back on
9/11, in the immediate aftermath
of 9/11, the estimates were over
5,000 dead at the World Trade
Center and people were comparing
this to Antietam as the
bloodiest day of sacrifice in
American history.
It turned out not to be the
case;
nevertheless.
What happened in the wake of
Antietam was that Lee's invasion
of the North had been stopped.
Now McClellan missed a
tremendous opportunity to press
the day.
This has always been a debate
among military historians,
and you can read,
oh God, hundreds of pages on
this, if you care to.
It's always been a debate as to
whether if McClellan had
followed this up could he have
literally crushed Lee's army
with the Potomac at his back and
in effect ended the war?
There surely was that
possibility but the day at
Antietam had been so devastating
to both forces that McClellan
did not move;
in fact, he did not move for
days.
It's also true though that
McClellan kept in reserve at
Antietam, and it was this act,
I think, more than anything
else, that got Lincoln finally
to go out there by October 3 and
fire McClellan.
McClellan kept about 20,000 of
his troops in reserve at
Antietam, always fearing that he
was outnumbered;
he didn't use them.
And in a military sense had
someone like Grant been in
charge at Antietam,
it is entirely possible Lee
would've been defeated and at
least the war in the East ended.
But that was not the case.
Lee retreated back into
Virginia to fight again.
This is a Mathew Brady
photograph, taken of Lincoln
meeting with McClellan.
This is McClellan right here.
There's also a famous photo of
them sitting in that same tent
you may have seen;
Burns uses it in the series.
It was in this meeting that
Lincoln went out to meet with
McClellan to urge him to move,
to push into northern Virginia,
to push after Lee's Army in
early autumn,
while the weather was so good.
And McClellan did not move,
and a couple of days after that
he was fired;
and fired for good.
Although McClellan will not
leave history of course,
he will come back to be the
Democratic Party's candidate for
president in 1864 against
Abraham Lincoln.
Now it is, of course,
in the wake of Antietam that
Lincoln issued his Emancipation
Proclamation.
Let me turn to that now and
explain why and how emancipation
became the new cause of the war.
Now, let's discuss Lincoln for
a moment, first.
The biggest problem with
Abraham Lincoln has always been
not--that is in how we interpret
him and treat him,
understand him,
use him, which we do
constantly.
Every president,
every American politician,
as David Donald once said
famously in the 1950s,
"has to get right with
Lincoln."
Everybody uses him.
We twist him all inside out and
make him say whatever we want
him to say.
And there's no other American
in our history who has been
given credit for more apocryphal
quotations, than Abraham
Lincoln.
A little later in the course
I'll use a few of them,
at the end of--when we get to
the end of the war.
But the problem with Lincoln is
indeed his ambiguity,
the reality of his historical
ambiguity.
There is a puzzling dualism
about him.
There are two,
at least two,
seeming incompatible legends,
if you want,
about Abraham Lincoln.
One has him as the kind of
awkward, amiable,
storytelling,
rail splitting,
frontier folk hero,
everybody's favorite homespun,
granddaddy with a corncob pipe,
who might just tell you a
little raunchy story,
and have you chuckling;
he's kind of fun.
The other though is the
towering political genius,
the moral leader,
the shaper of a nation's
destiny, savior of the Union and
the Great Emancipator.
He never quite asked for any of
those.
Everybody needs to claim him
though.
There's a brilliant essay on
this by an historian named Scott
Sandage.
It came out about ten years
ago, it's called "A Marble House
Divided."
It's all about the Lincoln
Memorial.
A lot of you you've probably
been to the Lincoln Memorial.
It is America's secular temple.
Everybody uses it.
The Ku Klux Klan has held
rallies at Lincoln's temple.
Martin Luther King gave the
Dream speech at Lincoln's
temple.
It's been used by every extreme
of American political culture.
If you want to claim the
nation's attention,
go to the nation's temple and
claim old Abe,
up behind you.
He was never very open about
himself, never wrote an
autobiography,
didn't write many
autobiographical sentences as a
matter of fact;
didn't live long enough to do
that.
He was never an abolitionist.
He actually had a lot of
personal contempt for radical
abolitionists.
He didn't like a lot of their
arguments and he didn't like
their tactics and strategies.
He was a genius with language;
no, no, there's no question
about that.
We've never had a president who
could use words,
who could find the music of
words, like Lincoln.
He wrote every word and every
sentence of every one of his
speeches and every one of his
great public letters.
Jim McPherson even went so far
as to write an article saying
how Lincoln won the war with
metaphors.
I don't know whether a metaphor
can win you a war.
Strongest battalions might be a
little more important in the
end.
Who knows?
Is he the symbol,
though, of the man who held
back emancipation as a white
supremacist,
or is he the symbol of the man
who outgrew his prejudices,
and those of his time,
to become the emancipator?
Or was he just a shrewd
politician, kind of finding the
middle ground and seeing how the
wind was going to blow if he
tried this or if he threw up
that balloon,
or if he tried that?
Now there are many ways to
reflect on Lincoln.
My own favorite expression
about him--and there are
thousands of these--but my own
favorite comes from W.E.B.
DuBois, the great black scholar
of the twentieth century,
who I think really captured all
sides of Lincoln in one
quotation.
This was DuBois,
in an editorial he wrote in
1922 in The Crisis
magazine.
He wrote it at the time of the
unveiling of the Lincoln
Memorial.
He also wrote it at a time when
he was fed up with all of the
national honoring and
celebration of Robert E.
Lee.
So it may have--that
celebration of Lee,
which disgusted DuBois,
maybe had had something to do
with how he wrote this
expression about Lincoln.
But this is DuBois on Lincoln,
quote: "I love him,
not because he was perfect,
but because he was not perfect,
and yet triumphed.
There was something left so
that at the crisis he was big
enough to be inconsistent,
cruel, merciful,
peace loving,
a fighter, despising negroes
and letting them fight,
and vote, protecting slavery
and freeing slaves.
He was a man,
a big, inconsistent,
brave man."
I'd argue, my friends,
that the most important thing
you can grasp about Abraham
Lincoln is that he had the
capacity for growth.
He was big enough to be
inconsistent,
or as Emerson once put it,
consistency's a hobgoblin of
simple minds.
Remember all that language
about flip-flopping in the 2004
election?
One of the candidates was
alleged to have been a
flip-flopper all the time.
Well, if Abraham Lincoln hadn't
been a flip-flopper we wouldn't
have had the Emancipation
Proclamation.
So here's to flip-flopping.
[laughter]
Lincoln's early record on
slavery is interesting.
As early as 1837 he was one of
only two representatives in the
Illinois Legislature to vote
against a resolution declaring
the right of slave ownership;
he was twenty-eight years-old
at that time.
He has one two-year term in the
House of Representatives.
During that term,
which was the Mexican War,
he found himself appalled at
the slave trade in the District
of Columbia.
You could go visit slave
auctions, as I've said before,
I think, two or three blocks
down the street from the
capitol.
He called that slave market,
quote, "a sort of Negro livery
stable where droves of Negroes
are collected,
temporarily kept and finally
taken to Southern markets,
precisely like droves of
horses."
He also said during that same
term, "If the Negro is a man,
why then my ancient faith
teaches me that all men are
created equal and that there can
be no moral right in connection
with one man's making a slave of
another."
At the same time Lincoln though
was a Henry Clay Whig.
He was a supporter of the
Compromise of 1850.
He believed in compensation to
slave owners as a way,
a hope, of setting up some kind
of gradual emancipation plan.
And he believed,
as Henry Clay had founded it,
in this idea--at least he did
for awhile--this idea of
colonization,
of sending blacks either to
Africa or to the Caribbean or to
Central America.
I don't have time to stop on
those fabulous Lincoln-Douglas
debates where you can find every
extreme of Abraham Lincoln.
I was once given an assignment
in a junior seminar as an
undergraduate.
Old Fred Williams at Michigan
State sent us to the Lincoln
Collected Papers and he said,
"Your assignment is to come
back with one passage
demonstrating that Lincoln was
anti-slavery and believed in
emancipation and come back with
one passage showing that he was
a white supremacist."
Now, growing up a Lincoln
lover, and I thought "oh,
dear."
That's like you've been raised
in a certain religion and
somebody says go read the
Bhagavad-Gita or read the Koran
or study Buddhism for awhile.
I did that too for awhile;
I didn't learn much but--.
[Laughter]
And sure enough you can find
all those extremes in the
Lincoln-Douglas debates.
We also know,
of course, that he was a free
soiler and he's most famous in
the South,
of course, for that language of
"putting slavery on a course of
ultimate extinction" in the
House Divided speech,
and elsewhere.
But once the war came,
the imperative about what to do
about slavery was a huge and
delicate and terrible political
question.
And this is the Lincoln that
will be forever debated and
it'll be debated next year like
it's never been debated because
it's the bicentennial of his
birth next year,
and as I've warned you,
it will be raining Lincoln
books and you will have to dodge
them next year.
[Laughter]
Now, after the war broke out
immediately some slaves began to
come into Union lines.
The first were at a fort in
Florida, and then as early as
May 1861, some slaves began to
come into Union lines,
handfuls, near Fortress Monroe
in Virginia.
And there was a Union commander
there, a political general,
a former Democrat,
before the war,
and anything but an
abolitionist,
Benjamin F.
Butler, who nevertheless when
these slaves came into his
lines, he realized,
no, wait a second,
the Confederates are over there
using these people to build
their fortifications,
maybe we could use them to
build our fortifications.
So why don't we confiscate them
and call them contraband of war?
They're property under the law,
call them contraband.
And the name stuck,
of course, and that name will
end up in poetry and in song,
and even in a law or two;
contraband property.
But, at the outset of the war,
in the summer of '61,
fall, winter of '61/'62,
into the spring of '62,
the first year of the war,
the official policy of the
Lincoln administration and of
the Union forces,
across the land,
the official policy,
was called denial of asylum.
It meant that any slave who
escaped into Union lines,
the officer in charge and
command of that unit had the
responsibility to return that
slave to his owner,
if the owner--this was the
impossible kicker--if the owner
was loyal to the Union.
If that owner was not loyal to
the Union and was in the
Confederate army or something,
then yes, you could admit that
slave to your lines as
contraband of war.
Now, of course if this had only
been a trickle of people here
and there, coming into Union
lines, possibly this could be
enforced.
But it wasn't enforceable.
How's that Union commander
going to go out and figure out,
hey, mister enslaved person,
is your owner loyal or disloyal
to the Union?
That slave is probably going to
say, "He's a Confederate,
what do you think?"
And, of course, most were.
Now, Congress took the lead
before Lincoln ever wrote an
Emancipation Proclamation,
although Lincoln was thinking
about this and working on this
all through that summer of 1862.
Congress took the lead.
Now this was a Congress,
remember, that is now dominated
by the Republican Party.
You got eleven southern states
out of the Union.
They don't have any senators,
they don't even have members in
the House of Representatives.
This is a northern Republican
majority, significant majority.
Now, they're going to run into
trouble in the fall
congressional elections of 1862,
and they're going to lose some
of those seats because of what
they're doing now.
Congress took the lead;
it passed an Article of War in
March of 1862 which said that
fugitive slaves must be admitted
to Union camps.
It didn't say what their status
would be, it didn't define
anybody.
It left their legal status
vague.
It just said any escaped slave
must now be admitted.
Now, the reason they did that
is because this denial of asylum
policy had caused chaos in a lot
of Union units.
A brief example.
Remember this guy Charles
Brewster whose letters I read
from the other day;
this guy from Massachusetts
whose letters I edited and so
on?
Well Charlie Brewster,
this racist from Northampton,
Massachusetts,
28-years-old by now,
nevertheless in the late fall
of 1861, he took a runaway slave
who was 17-years-old and named
David,
into his personal care--he made
him his personal servant.
This is after Brewster got his
commission as an officer.
He even wrote home to his
sister, several times,
asking his sister to send
stocking caps,
socks, an old pair of pants.
He even named the shirts that
he wanted to put on his David;
it was as though he was
dressing him.
And Brewster was determined
never to send that kid back to
slavery.
But down came the orders,
by January, early February
1862, that all fugitive slaves
within their camps must be
returned to their owners,
if those owners came to the
Union lines to retrieve them.
And the fugitive named David
had his owner waiting at the
camp.
There was a near mutiny in the
10^(th) Massachusetts,
which was Brewster's regiment,
between those soldiers who
wanted to protect these fugitive
slaves and free them,
in effect, and those who did
not.
And this went on in hundreds of
regiments.
Brewster was threatened with
court martial and being run out
of the Army if he didn't give
back this fugitive slave.
His compromise was that he took
this young David out into the
woods and he said,
"Get out of here,
run.
I'll just tell them you ran
away."
And that's what he did.
By that spring,
Congress decided any fugitive
slave who escapes to Union lines
must be accepted.
In April of 1862,
Congress, on the 16^(th) of
April--and this was a very
significant law--they passed
abolition,
the end of slavery in the
District of Columbia.
They gave $300 per slave in
compensation to those owners of
slaves in the district.
The District of Columbia in
1862 had 3,100 slaves.
They also put up,
I think the figure was about
$300,000.00 in that bill,
where they provided for the
possible colonization of blacks
voluntarily to foreign countries
as a result of emancipation,
a policy the Lincoln
administration now was
supporting.
Then third, in June of '62,
Congress, by majority vote,
sort of threw a great deal of
American history on the dust
heap and they abolished slavery
forever in the Western
Territories;
arguably the single most
important cause of the Civil
War.
A stroke of the pen,
in June of '62,
they ended slavery,
in spite of the Dred Scott
decision.
Now, remember what the Dred
Scott decision had said.
Here was Congress passing a law
in direct opposition to a
Supreme Court decision.
It's an argument for not having
too many civil wars,
you see, because Congress might
end up doing anything in the
midst of a civil war,
and they surely did here.
And then finally,
on July 17,1862,
Congress passed what was called
the Second Confiscation Act.
There'd been a First
Confiscation Act passed back in
August of '61.
Even in the First Confiscation
Act--and by the way,
these were acts authorizing
Union forces to confiscate
Confederate property.
Even in the First Confiscation
Act, back in August of 1861,
slaves were mentioned as
property;
their status was still very
vague.
But in the Second Confiscation
Act, July '62,
the law explicitly freed slaves
of all persons,
quote, "in rebellion,"
anywhere;
any slave of anyone supporting
the Confederacy.
It did everything the
Emancipation Proclamation will
later do and then some.
It was in some ways more
extensive because it included
all parts of the South,
including those Border States
that had not seceded from the
Union.
Now, with Congress already
having done these things,
by July of '62--and by the way,
this is all during the
Peninsula Campaign,
down in Virginia.
The Second Confiscation Act was
passed in the immediate wake of
the Seven Days battle.
Lee is deciding to invade the
North.
Lincoln, as you may know the
story--if you've read Team of
Rivals by Doris Goodwin you
know it-- would hang out at the
War Department.
He'd go there for some solitude.
He had a private little office
there.
He began to draft an
Emancipation Proclamation as a
legal brief, a legal document,
and he kept it in a locked door
of a desk at the War Department.
Supposedly there was one or two
guards that knew about it;
I'm not sure about that.
But he was beginning to draft
an Emancipation Proclamation
probably as early as June,
certainly by July of '62.
The pressure now mounted from
every direction.
He secretly held meetings with
a delegation of Delaware,
and a delegation from Kentucky,
trying to convince them to
institute gradual emancipation
plans over time with
compensation to slave owners
that would free slaves over a
35-year period.
This was Lincoln the
gradualist, this was Lincoln
trying to condition public
opinion.
Delaware at that point only had
1,800 slaves.
There were far more slaves in
the District of Columbia than
there were in all of Delaware.
But the Delaware delegation
that came to the White House to
meet with Lincoln told him
unequivocally no,
they weren't going to touch
slavery for fear of what it
might ignite.
Lincoln waited and waited.
He was attacked by Horace
Greeley in the New York
Herald Tribune,
as you know.
Read the famous Greeley letter
in the Johnson Collection.
This is the famous passage in
August of '62 where Lincoln
said, "I will save the Union by
freeing all the slaves;
or I will save the Union by
freeing none of the slaves.
My aim in the end is to save
the Union."
But read that entire letter,
not just that quote,
I'm going to leave that to you;
read the entire letter,
because he's actually honest on
both sides of the semicolon.
Look for his semicolon,
and judge both sides.
He's a crafty cat,
you got to read him closely.
Lincoln needed a battlefield
victory, he needed some kind of
battlefield success,
and he gets that of course with
Antietam.
In the wake of Antietam,
five days afterwards,
22^(nd) September '62,
Lincoln issued the preliminary
Emancipation Proclamation.
That preliminary Emancipation
Proclamation said that slaves in
the United States,
in the states in rebellion,
would be freed on January
1^(st).
There was a carrot and a stick.
The stick was emancipation and
conquest, if the Union forces
could ever do it;
and the carrot was in effect he
invited the Confederate states
to throw down their arms,
give up the war,
come back to the Union,
by January 1^(st).
They're not going to do it,
of course, but he was hoping;
or was he hoping?
I'm going to leave you with
this.
Back in Virginia there was a
young slave, twenty-two
years-old.
His name was John Washington.
He'd grown up Fredericksburg,
Virginia.
Had a white father whom he
never knew, a slave mother named
Sarah.
She taught him to read and
write.
He grows up an urban slave with
lots of skills,
highly valued,
probably a brilliant young man.
He got hired out five times in
the late 1850s and the first
year of the war.
He married his sweetheart in
January 1862 in the African
Baptist Church in
Fredericksburg.
And he chose his moment of
escape at the first appearance
of Union forces along the
Rappahannock River in
Fredericksburg on the 18^(th) of
April, 1862.
He left a narrative that he
wrote after the war that I had
the great good fortune to have
lopped in my lap and have
recently published a book about
it.
And in that narrative he tells
this remarkable story of the day
of his escape.
He even drew a map of
Fredericksburg of the day of his
escape, including a glossary of
sixteen sites and buildings and
crossroads on that map,
as though he wanted the world
to see as well as hear his
story.
And John tells this story--he's
twenty-two years-old--he tells
the story of all the white
people evacuating Fredericksburg
and his mistress,
Mrs.
Tolliver, is literally packing
her china and her silver,
and she says one day,
"Now John, you'll be with us
tomorrow, you'll be with us
tomorrow."
She's assuming his loyalty.
And he says,
"Yes Misses,
yes Misses, I'll be with you
tomorrow."
And then his next scene is he's
got a hotel where he's been
hired out as a steward,
almost like an assistant
manager, and he describes all
the white people fleeing the
hotel and fleeing the streets of
Fredericksburg,
and he says he took the twelve
workers up on the roof of the
hotel--and the hotel was called
The Shakespeare,
I kid you not.
He takes all the black workers
up on the roof of the hotel
where they could see across the
river and see what he called
"the gleam of the Yankees'
bayonets."
And then he brought them all
back down into the kitchen and
he poured a round of drinks,
and he held a toast,
and the toast was "To the
Yankees."
And then he instructed his
fellow workers,
he said, to get out of there.
"But," he said,
"don't get too far from the
Yankees."
And then John Washington walked
two blocks down to the river,
he witnessed the formal
surrender of Fredericksburg,
he saw the bridges being burned
by the Confederate forces,
and he walked one mile up
river,
and he said he crossed the
river at Fickland's Mill;
and the old stone ruins of that
mill are still there.
So I know exactly where he
crossed the river.
He got into a rowboat,
he crossed, and that night he
slept in the camp of the 30^(th)
New York Volunteers.
A captain in that regiment
named Ladd, l-a-d-d,
formally freed him,
he said,
based on the law that had just
been passed by Congress
forty-eight hours earlier in
Washington,
freeing the slaves in the
District of Columbia.
John Washington spent the rest
of that summer as a camp hand
and a guide for the Union Army,
all the way through Second
Manassas.
He dated his arrival in
Washington, D.C.
as part of the first great wave
of freedmen into the capital,
as September 1.
And by the following year I
found him in a City Directory
record, living at his first
address on 19^(th) Street in
Washington.
He had his wife,
his newborn child,
his mother and his 68-year-old
grandmother living there with
him.
Apart from, beneath,
next to, underneath this great
military and political story,
thousands and thousands of John
Washingtons are freeing
themselves.